how would you rate yourself on a scale
of one to ten in the bedroom
um I'm gonna say eight point something
right okay everybody can get better I'm
humble you know I can get better right
it depends also how much you've had to
drink you know what kind of if it's
morning afternoon depends on the woman
uh-huh it depends how many women
a lot of treadmill a lot of treadmill
yeah yeah yeah you better go on the
treadmill you've got a yeah you've got a
very big reputation that you need to
hold up to and by big reputation I'd be
massive peanuts
foreign
either you've just grown a lot of hair
on your chest
because the Obama's become like a force
of nature in its own right it's been you
know I believe there are like websites
devoted to it and there were children
named after it and it's become it's a
huge phenomenon in the figurative sense
your bum is enormous
[Applause]
new hairdo
she said actually you're falling out of
your dress
I'm being polite thank you Jay how are
they doing how are we uh
I want you to give me a snake I'll give
you a snake cup young lady yeah
[Music]
you will receive one and you will enjoy
it
okay
you had one job
in my head you were so much better with
balls
[Applause]
when someone sleeps with you for the
first time okay
yeah bear with me there's a point to
this do you think they try a little bit
harder
like trying to spin around and you know
because you're small like I'll pick you
up
pretty
no no no pretty girl embarrassing
um ready kiss help please
this is fascinating you shot the entire
movie in Africa
you know what a real butt feels like
right oh yeah
a little flirty fun ad
that's good oh oh that's real flirty
okay okay uh I'm lost I'm not happy
let's see happy
[Music]
I like this eye contact bad and pouty
sad and Patty with you sitting there oh
that was cute she's always in my DM I
just want to let you fishy
tell you the truth I can't tell you what
she says okay
there's millions that are in your DMs if
that's the case you know what she says
she says even though I'm Spanish you
know I like that chocolate
and I tell her once you go check you
never go back
now have you ever been a Fool in Love
have you ever done that over a guy like
like they're women hello ladies we all
have it
yes yes
oh you want me to tell you
believe me yeah I'm enjoying it
I mean no no but I'm sitting here and I
get this Jay hi
[Applause]
I
don't want to sit and stare but I get
this
I promise I never sat down in this dress
this is my brother no that's not a
problem at all
the problem is you've never sat down in
the dress my problem is I can't stand up
[Applause]
earlier that she would actually pay
Russell for sex
I've come here to discuss a possible
price plan
it's very nice to be here I feel like
I've been misled by the name of the show
slightly I've been here a minute and no
one's done anything remotely loose
and you have beautiful teeth by the way
thank you yes I was I was privy to many
experiments my teeth are terrible my mom
would all you don't need to go to the
orthodontist this is what I remember
what I'll say whenever you get a few
minutes do this
just push out okay and your teeth will
come my father might have some different
advice for you but you know whatever
works you know that's a great dress I'm
sorry thank you
thank you very much
now now what did I read oh there was a
tabloid story I'm I'm trying to look in
the camera I'm sorry
you know I'm Still A Guy I'm so glad I'm
so glad you like it no it is a great
dress but it's hard I see I'm talking to
you I'm looking you in the eye I'm I'm
talking to you
[Music]
thank you no one sees them on TV but I
know that they're there so we know
they're in there yeah are you single I
am you're handsome wow thank you tell me
more yeah you have cute socks really big
muscles Barbie Olivia you guys look hot
guys this is amazing can you take off
your shirt which one all of them all of
it sure
you could start with the jacket here if
I do it seductible yeah maybe maybe I'll
undo one button
how about two buttons two buttons two
more buttons yes otherwise we won't
speak yeah
it's like
you're like bribing me okay how about
now that's a lot
what what
so we're gonna do the interview like
this
okay
that looks great so we're gonna do the
rest of the interview like this yes you
should wear your shirt like that all the
time I feel really comfortable I'm
really good at riding on the back of
men's horses
for that to be dirty it's
just no you did mean it to be good
and that's okay I'm feeling feisty
because I'm extremely messed up right
now
I'm happy for you
what is in that cup
something
juice oh what
yeah you can have a drink over good put
your hands on the snake and then drink
up this is the side you drink out of
right that's a side I drink out of
it
you can have another drink if you want
[Applause]
because because now it's like you and I
Have Kissed before you even have the
chance to kiss Morgan Freeman only if I
drank over then would we have guests
drink out of it just do it you gotta do
that side yeah there you go
[Applause]